Oh, I just love the smell of a good royalty deal in the morning.
[Off-Camera] Good morning Clay. Good morning Kevin.
[Off-Camera] Hey, morning Ken.
This is it. The Shark Tank set, right here.
These tables, these chairs.
Right here baby. This is where it happens.
You come down that corridor.
It's got to take a lot of guts to walk through that thing, when the doors are closed knowing what's on the other side
The doors are closed, they're freaking out for sure.
They don't know what's on the other side because they've always been practicing without the Sharks there.
Then they make the walk.
The doors open up.
Then it gets really tough.
I mean.
I've been watching it for ten years, but I know it's hard.
But, you know what's gonna happen in about 20 minutes, it will start all over again.
I love this show, it's so much fun to make.
Because every deal is different and after all you only need one good idea.
It changes your life forever.
Okay, I'm at 23rd.
Yeah, what about it?
Yeah, thats when I-
What date is this?
[Off-Camera] So, where's the white space in your portfolio right now?
What kind of deal haven't you done that you kind of want to do? Like, you know, you've got a-
[Kevin] Music, I want to do music.
It's all the producers. We don't do enough music stuff. We do everything else.
It's hard to find a deal in music that, you know, isn't already owned by the behemoth's.
But, you know, we've had bands and stuff like that, but, we don't-
Finding them a music deal would be very cool.
That would definitely be an interesting area.
I'm also interested in doing more with gourmet foods.
Because I've got-
you know, Chef Wonderful now is a
pretty big franchise on QVC.
We've been selling out everything to bring there.
I've brought cakes, gourmet beef-
doing chocolates and so if I see more gourmet items that would fit in my Chef Wonderful portfolio,
I'm gonna go for that stuff too.
[Off-Camera] From just my own person memory, it seems like Daymond and Barbra
do majority of the food deals.
I know Barbra did that-
[Kevin] That's all, that's all about to change.
Now it's Chef Wonderful, full steam ahead.
I'm gonna crush them with the cockroaches they are.
Where we've realized we don't have the same amount of value it's on business-to-business stuff. Because-
Why would you give up, you think of a syndication, you're getting 10 million eyeballs a week.
You want a product that everybody wants to buy. That's what works. When you get sophisticated technology that only a business buys
It's a limited opportunity.
And over time you see mostly investors
don't do those deals because they don't add a lot of value. Where I add value is a product
that needs to get on to the open market.
See I'm going with all the healthy options, salad, asparagus and tomato mozzarella.
Very clean living here.
Who gives a flying ****?
[Off-Camera] What's is it like to be in the tank with Kevin?
[Rohan] In the tank, do you mean Mr. Wonderful?
[Off-Camera] Mr. Wonderful.
[Rohan] First of all, he doesn't like going by Kevin, you need to address him. But it's virtually impossible to be in the tank without-
wine, chateaubriand, and death coming up with Kevin.
[Off-Camera] How's his French?
[Rohan] His French is terrible. He just takes the word Chateaubriand and says Cha-toe-breon and that's his French.
He's pretending to be a Quebecois because he would like those votes, but let's be honest.
[Kevin] All together, the caramelizing with crepe flambe at the end creates this masterpiece.
[Off-Camera] Any words of the advice for fellow entrepreneurs?
[Rohan] I think if you're coming to the Tank be confident, be passionate and please, please, please have a real plan.
Or otherwise you'll get eaten up by the Sharks.
[Kevin] Don't be a greedy pig!